luke and tom here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're here on an
uninhabited island in the middle of
scotland and we are doing survival
camping
[Music]
hey leon
all right guys we're in the northwest of
scotland i'm here with leon with
wildwood bushcraft we're gonna go do
some survival camping and foraging and
uh just all sorts of fun things leon
here has an awesome survival school that
you can come here and learn all sorts of
survival techniques i'll put a link in
the video description below and we came
here and did a trip with him two years
ago yeah we had so much fun we decided
to come back and give it another try
yeah this wind's gonna be crazy it's
gonna want to spin us around a bunch
we'll deal with it
oh
well here we are guys
a deserted island
in the middle of a lock in scotland
a little breeze takes care of the no
seems
the midges
all right tom where do you think we
should build the tent you like this spot
right there hey tom you remember what
leon showed us last time
he said before you set up your shelter
lay down in it see what it feels like
now what do you think tom is there any
roots or sticks in your back any any uh
stumps or anything
all
make you right nice
yeah that's that's pretty level
reasonably soft no roots in our back all
right
all right tom you got to get out your
midge hood yes
yeah i need to go in
go and tuck that into your into your
rain jacket
there you go
tommy hates the bug spray so he prefers
the hood
[Music]
she looks buttoned down
we've set up a tent
we're going to walk around the island
and kind of explore and see what's on
the island
group of people over there are sea
trekking and they're hiking they jump in
the water swim to the next island hike
then jump in the water and swim to shore
and hike basically triathloners who
don't like bicycles they're heading off
to that next little group of rocks right
over there
oh that looks so cold
looks like they made it across
oh that's hardcore
this material
oh yeah
we've got it frazzled because it kind of
frazzles up you know it's very handy for
getting fires going
you know people who don't live in an
environment like this have a hard time
understanding how wet things are
they can just be wet for weeks and weeks
in an environment like this so finding
fire starter can be challenging
look at there
there's these crab shells all over the
island the herons and the birds catch
the crabs and come up with the trees and
eat them
and you just find
shells
although oh that's a good one look at
that plus
if you want to save one for mom that's a
good one
yeah
so we've got this this bit around here
actually like very um like a little
rosette yeah the flower and it's very
spongy so it kind of contains quite a
lot of water
if you're looking for water on a small
island you can find it in the moss
this type of moss is like a sponge
and all the water that comes out of it
you can drink it there's a little bit of
iodine in it so
might be a little bit cleaner than
drinking out of a puddle here in
scotland there's a lot of peat in the
ground so any standing water is going to
be dark and have that tanning peat
flavor to it so if you can drink it out
of the moss it's going to be better than
drinking out of a puddle
yeah you got you found some wood sorrel
yeah
see this little plant looks like clover
kind of
it's called wood sorrel anytime you have
a really wet forest you seem to find
these we get this out in the northwest
of the us as well too
the difference between clover and wood
sorrel is that these look like little
hearts and clovers
doesn't have this little clef in there
the wood sorrel has kind of a tangy
rhubarb aftertaste it's really subtle
it's nice come on enough wood sorrel
come on
they are toxic not like massively but
yeah you don't want to eat the spark
that comes off obviously you don't want
to damage the tree you just take it off
where it's coming off normally this is
very good for starting fires yeah yeah
yeah but it also it will burn up very
fast
well we got a crab pot and we want to
set it out today and we found a spot
with a bunch of limpets so we're gonna
go and uh catch some limpets for crab
bait and of course you can also eat
limpets
oh you got him got him
we got it
oh here's another one
oh look at the size of those have you
ever had limpet tikka masala no
well hey i'm not gonna be able to say
that tomorrow okay yes i think two would
be enough i think oh yeah
oh yeah collapsible one is gonna come
through or not i think they'll stay in i
need to make sure it's not too much
excess
oh that wind's pretty nasty i think i
might put the fishing rod up for a
little bit try to get some lunch made
okay here why don't you open up the
pouch see what we got
okay so you got a ferris rod and a
striker there yeah or we could do actual
foot and steel i'd say maybe try with
the ferrous rod if you go like this
your hand hits what you're trying to
work on if you go like this and you
pull it
it doesn't knock your fire around
now this is hard conditions with the
winds blowing like this and it's rainy
so oh this could be challenging even for
somebody who's done it a ton of times
you want to give it a try yeah okay let
me see if i can do it i'm all talk so
far
that's growing it's growing
yes
well tom we need some seaweed for lunch
you're gonna get get some seaweed for us
yeah all right here take the camera i'll
watch the fire hi
let's go do this
net on me
so i'm going to put that on
if you can grab a good handful of that
like a good amount i made maybe two
handfuls
you guys gathered some seaweed for lunch
yeah i got
a little rat rat channel drug yeah
channel rack panel rack gut
yeah gut weight it's supposed to look a
little bit like intestines when it's
lying in the water um right so we're
going to cut this up and we'll do the
fry it all right and then we'll put it
into some flat uh bread mix and then
we'll make a bread with it all right
oh i got stuffing the dropper there
so this is kind of a little bit blandish
you know it's got a bit of salty tastes
and it's quite textural
green look at it it's gone from brown to
a nice pretty green
there's color stinging metal going in
the pot there
yeah you got makeup i'm nine right now
all right so what what we got for lunch
here tom super new toast yes this is
this is pot noodle which sounds like
something a stoner would eat but here in
the uk they call kappa noodle pot noodle
so not not pot of noodle pot noodle what
noodles like a
brand name that you'll get very similar
super noodles
yeah yeah
imagine it's the
getting stinging nettle
pot of noodle pot noodles
there we go
yeah it's herbal tea
here let's cool it off so we can yeah
yeah put it right there it's a little
hot there so let let that cool
yeah i don't come back too yeah
come grab grab a plate
please you very much
all right we got a scottish bannock here
with some gut weed and channel rack
that is good
all right we got the stinging nettle tea
here we're going to try
um
not bad at all it's it's um it reminds
me of fireweed actually tastes a lot
like a fireweed if you've ever chewed it
which is a very specific thing to
compare it to
i think somebody a lot more vogue than
me would say it has earthy undertones
but
but nobody knows what that means so you
know
it's stuff just like the silver
all right
you like the stinging nettle tea it's
amazing
yeah we'll get to we'll get we'll have a
nice warm drink in the morning that
sounds really lovely yeah
here let's go over here and find some
moss to use to wash the dishes
here's something right here
you grab that spongy moss
yeah it kind of it kind of soaks up the
grease it gets the grease off
i like the spade in the moss look at
that that that works a lot better look
at that
all right guys we're testing two
different types of mosses to see which
one does the dishes better
okay
it soaks it up but it leaves a bed
oh look at that healthy the streak free
after finish there
that's right nine out of ten housewives
recommend spaying the moss
there you go
all right well we finished up lunch and
we're gonna head down to the beach and
uh try a little survival exercise we're
gonna see if we can take some flotsam
and jetson that might wash up on shore
make a raft out of it
i like to sort of present it to
whoever's doing it as a bit of a
challenge to work out but i'll give you
make these ourselves yeah you want you
want to make a raft
so the four parts there um
if you were to try to ride this barrel
in the water
and you were to get on top of this
barrel like this
what would happen
here you go
it would just roll right over and dump
you in the water right
yeah what's your idea buddy i think you
have see these handles we can take the
rope and tie them together uh-huh
somehow tie these attach these ones to
the back
i think we should do
that
here why don't you put those two barrels
together and we'll tie the handles
together on this one too
what happens if you put some weight here
it wants to pop up doesn't it it wants
to fold up like that
we should have
the handles
here should we test it out yeah
let's see let's see how it does
oh that's so heavy
her in tie hop on it
just tie a rope on you
we're gonna go really
shallow it worked
that'll make you have to go against the
wind a little bit
yeah you're kind of getting there though
toby i'm impressed
first off that was your idea to put the
handles together you know tom with the
way the wind is
if you were going out of this inlet the
wind would push you straight towards
that shore so
i think you could do it tom
and but for the love of my child i i
would be curious to see it happen
dub high fives yeah well done success
yeah yeah
there you go
again
oh that was fun well leon baited that
crab pot with the limpets and put it out
there a couple hours ago
and uh we're gonna go and check it and
just see if we got any crabs or lobsters
or anything in the pot
fat dad and a little boat
oh no don't ram mr leon you naughty
child
okay that might have been mostly the
wind okay
we need more soundings mr nichols
there you go tom
yeah pull that buoy up and throw it in
the back of the boat
oh i see it right there oh is there
something in there maybe
yeah
here how about this glass for sure
the question is do we eat them or send
them back to the orphanage you could eat
it yeah you put them on youtube and send
him home
total survival mode then yes definitely
i don't remember that whole thing
let's see if he's like a blue crab you
can
pinch them on the button they can't get
you
but they'll reach down a bit
but kaitra
oh oh a little sugarcoat you want to
send them back
all
right
well thank goodness for exoskeletons
yeah
something we caught something she's bad
for a short period of time yeah
look at this we're like on deadliest
catch we're crab fishermen now yeah we
got the rubber pants and everything
oh there's some big boys out here
look at the size of that thing
i call it mount olympics
welcome to the club kid
i kicked this limpet off the rock and it
flew about 10 feet through the air and
hit tommy in the back of the head
i think he's dead
look at a size comparison here
look at that thing that thing's like two
inches across
gut weed right here yeah
that's the gut weed so you get some of
the gut weed
get the good stuff that's really gutty
there you go
um okay
here's the perfect one right there okay
line it up aim it
yeah oh you got him you got him get him
he's dead dude
all right you got him
let's watch it with your foot oh i
knocked it off
all right you got him
tommy six limp it's zero here's another
one
yeah there we go yeah
yeah if you wanna
just break it off yeah see it's off the
ground so it's not as soggy
what do you think should i do ferris rod
or should i try to be fancy and use
flint and steel let's do foot and steel
a little bit of flint here
and uh got your steel got a striker
got some char cloth
and a little bit of jute
oh
we caught something there we go we got a
little ember there
this way please do you still see that
ember
it looks like it's sliding
go oh we go
there you go little
limp it
that's what he looks like when he takes
his hat off
hey you can eat them raw
not the best thing in the world but you
know they're they're not bad i got some
boiling bag rice and a jar of tikka
masala curry
we're going to have some foraged seafood
curry here we're going to have some
razor clams limpets
[Music]
leon's got some razor clams he harvested
a little while ago this bit that comes
out of here
so the foot is the best bit there's a
kind of guts here yeah we should don't
tend to eat so much yeah there goes the
razor clams
the steel little piece right here
nice that is nice
you wanna try a little bit a little bit
dumb okay so yellow ones
of course you can't have curry without a
little bread to go with it right yeah
there we go there we go all right go all
right we're gonna add the curry mix here
[Music]
look at that that actually looks like a
proper little curry there why don't you
grab a plate and a fork and pull out one
for me and one for you
well that looks really good look at that
okay there we go razor clam limpet
seaweed tikka masala
with uh bandit naan
that's good yeah you can't can't go to
the british isles without having a good
curry on a scale of one to ten how does
this compare to other limpet curries you
had i'm stuck in a 10.
[Laughter]
razor clam limp curry not bad at all
we'll have to do a pig nut vindaloo next
time
we got bellies full of seafood curry and
the wind has died down and the sun came
out a little bit this is turning out
pretty nice huh yeah you really wanted
to go out canoeing huh yeah
oh yeah it's still possible
look at this this is nice
that nice tommy you enjoy that thank you
what an absolutely gorgeous evening
you know with scottish weather you got
to be prepared for absolutely anything
including gorgeous moments just like
this
what do you think you think it's about
bedtime yeah all right we'll see you in
the morning leon
okay
tell me if you had a fun day yeah yeah i
saw that the strip is ending
it's seven o'clock and we've got to be
out of here by nine
so
we need to go and get everything packed
away and
cleaned up here pretty quick
a lovely day
the weather's been so much better than
it was forecast
hey hold on don't move i want
yeah look no joke those are ticks aren't
they get them off get kill them kill
them get them all last time we were here
at scotland the boys got into tons of
ticks
so we've got to definitely check
ourselves for ticks when we get home
well we're in scotland so we're going to
start the day off with some potato
scones we're going to warm up over the
fire and put some honey and butter on
them it's like
people in government
but i'm not like all right we got some
warm scones in our belly gotta clean up
and
start heading back
oh watch it well we just barely get
packed up and the rain's starting
are you having a good time yes i had an
amazing time oh good
leona thank you so much we had such a
great time thank you we're done we're
done young man listen if you guys are
ever in scotland check out wildwood
bushcraft he has classes here in
scotland and in england if i remember
correctly yes i'll put a link in the
video description below well listen if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every saturday morning and check the
link below for our five week tour of the
uk i'll put a link down there as soon as
i post that video thanks for watching
guys see you next saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]